over the years many fatal illnesses have
been overcome many human weaknesses
rendered Obsolete and the life
expectancy of humans has increased
significantly this is all good news for
you for me and all of humanity
but technology will keep evolving and
with it the Ambitions of those
scientists working on empowering us as
humans
is there a limit to these Ambitions is
it possible that with such ambition and
Technology we are going to be humans
with superpowers
[Music]
will we still be human another hidden
intentions behind the movement they call
transhumanism
[Music]
[Applause]
I once broke my hand as a child while
playing
on my way to the hospital I imagined
having it replaced with a bionic hand
I must have seen it in a movie and
thought it would cool
I went back home that day I'm fulfilled
with just plaster on my hand
[Music]
we know that it's not against the laws
of business it's just a well-known
marketing strategy if you're valuing
different lives in a different way this
could very well lead to a homework
things have changed and maybe it's time
for my childhood dreams to come true
implantable defibrillators can restore
your heartbeat
smart contact lenses
can record video
how far can technology lead the
evolution of the human body
how much better can we become
and is it all driven by the intention to
live a better life
I've always believed in endurance
and the power of will
no pain no gain as they say life has
taught me that the only way to improve
is through exerting effort
is that still true
maybe what I believed all my life is now
obsolete
it is already outdated by today's
scientific advances
biotechnology aims at shattering our
limits
at having improved versions of ourselves
by passing endurance and even the power
of will is that what transhumanism
promises
we've always used technology to support
our bodies
there are people who use crutches or
dentures and many other forms of support
but they say that transhumanism
is a complete Revolution
but is it something that can make our
lives better
the best way to know is to talk to
someone who has gone through this
process in person
in my research I found Rob Spence he's a
filmmaker who is blind in one eye and 9
years ago he replaced his eye with a
video camera
hi Rob thank you very much for taking
the time to talk to me my pleasure what
is transhumanism for you for me
transhumanism is a term that journalists
and academics have come up with I guess
I'm a transhumanist
but what it means is is people that add
technology to their bodies can you tell
me why did you decide to install a
camera inside your eye uh I had an
accident with a shotgun when I was nine
by the time I turned 30 the doctor said
you should remove your eye
but by that time I had become a
filmmaker I just thought why don't I
call some engineers and see if I could
put
a camera in there how do you think we
can use technology to make our bodies
better I know a lot of people who've
added technology to their bodies and for
many people
it's because they lost a part of their
body I think in general the main way
technology will join the body is stuff
like this like your phone but a phone is
a powerful computer and it just keeps
coming closer to the body Elon Musk for
example is looking at ways to add a
neural lace to the brain and he in fact
says that using your thumbs all the time
is barbaric do you believe that this
will be the future
we will become a hybrid between organic
beings and Technology yeah artificial
intelligence and human beings are are
destined to join there's a whole idea
that um you can become more than human
I'm a guy who lost his eye
and I wanted a cool eye camera that's
where I'm coming from but before I felt
like just a guy who lost his eye now
that I have an eye camera I feel a bit
cooler I feel nicer I feel better I feel
more technological I used to read a lot
of comics
and I would see these guys with glowing
red eyes I have a glowing red eye now so
I'm happy I'm a homo Excelsior
Rob Spencer's experience in
transhumanism makes sense
something in his body stopped working so
he exchanged it with something
artificial
this is not the only drive behind
transhumans
what about improving organs that
function without problems
is this the ultimate aim of
transhumanism
a better human life
or is this just a story to cover other
hidden intentions
I've easily found many voices against
transhumanism
but it wasn't that easy to find one of
the better informed experts
he is the author of The revealing book
on the subject his name is Antonio
dieges professor of philosophy at the
University of Malaga I asked him if
there could be hidden interests behind
transhumanism
there are several interests behind
transhumanism economic and and power
interest is no accident for example that
the big tech companies in Silicon Valley
are so clearly supporting the
transhumanist this course and are
financing with large amount of money
project that clear the transhumanist
inspiration they repeat the idea that
artificial intelligence will change
completely our life in near future this
is a well-known marketing strategy to to
sell their products in artificial
intelligence system for example
it is easy to take a position against
transhumanism as one watches from a
distance
but if we watch our closest and dearest
people grow older weaker and become in
pain then our position may be different
and we would probably do anything to
help them
but can transhumanism really eliminate
pain
stop aging
can it prolong the lives of those we
love
is it possible that transhumanism has a
long-term goal to eliminate death
that the human species becomes immortal
[Music]
have found that better humans is the
world's first specifically transhumanist
biomedical research organization
they focus on the effects of Aging
and its President James Clement
can tell me all about it
hi James thank you for talking to me
nice to see you I wanted to ask you
what is transhumanism
transhumanism is really
the idea that you can use these
so-called exponential Technologies like
nanotechnology biotechnology
information science artificial
intelligence and cognitive science or
Neuroscience to allow humans to exceed
our evolved genetics
so are we trying to make our lives
easier or are we trying to reach
immortality if you want to be a super
centenarian
someone who lives to 110 and is still
gardening at 107 108 years old still
riding a bicycle uh then you first have
to get to 99. maybe we get there maybe
we don't but we know that it's not
against the laws of physics we have
bowhead whales mammals like us that are
living the 200 and longer so we know
this is possible so immortality is not
exactly the station but rather the
direction correct very well put I I
think the first
um objective really is to diminish human
suffering okay what about in the long
run
do you think immortality can become an
objective I think that immortality is
more of a philosophical question I think
the best terminology is maybe something
like indefinite lifespan but whether
people even choose to live beyond let's
say a thousand years or ten thousand
years I I think we don't know we don't
know at what point you know people may
choose not to live further
immortality
death is inherent to life how could we
be both human and immortal
birth and death are the constant truths
in our existence
now they say that in the future we will
be born in a different way
and that we will not die
[Music]
thank you
by the way this isn't just an expensive
toy
this is the future all of us one of
these days will have similar hands can
you imagine imagine we live without pain
can you imagine if you play the guitar
with a hand like this
where your level of accuracy and speed
will be
no dude thanks I don't agree with this I
love my hand on my guitar because you're
an antique man and you like pain
pain is something very important in life
it teaches us many things and then it
passes but the goal of medicine since it
was established is to reduce pain and
extend the lives of people isn't this
the same thing as well
that we alleviate pain is something and
to live longer is something but that we
stop dying is something completely
different
whatever dude
as you wish
to stick to pain
[Music]
there's a folk proverb that says may God
grant you eternal life
I never thought that one day this would
be so literal
[Music]
science aspiring to Divine powers
in our culture in history we learn
stories which tell us that every time
people try to play God they were
demolished by God
like Pharaoh with Moses Atlantis and the
people of ayad and many other Tales
do we really want this
what does it morally imply
I need to find someone of a different
background
is the person to speak to
humanism
you know it's I think one of the key
questions for this whole debate issues
like autonomy well it begins maybe with
the parents making decisions about the
physical makeup of the child maybe even
the state at some stage coming in and
making decisions about the genetic
makeup of its citizens there's also
issues of Justice there's a scholar
called Musa Ferber and he talks about
there being a nano divide I.E a divide
in access to nanotechnologies another
interesting concept from Jurgen habermas
he makes a differentiation between
what's grown and what's made and I think
that's key to the Human Condition we're
supposed to struggle with things we're
supposed to overcome challenges we're
supposed to be challenged
one of the concerns from an Islamic
perspective is the idea that comes from
Nick Bostrom he talks about Humanity
being a half-baked Creation in the Quran
there's this idea that we have the
potential to be so high but we also have
the potential to go low and that's part
of the divine plan is that we have the
choice I think what transhumanists want
to do is they want to take that away I
think from again for maybe looking at
the Islamic idea of jihad and nafs I.E
struggling against the self you know
challenging the self-battling against
the self as we all know that's a
lifelong journey and sometimes we do
well and sometimes we don't but we learn
from it transhumanism I guess is looking
to bypass all of that is
transhumanism is probably one of the
fruits of the Enlightenment and another
one of the fruits of the Enlightenment
that came you know in the western world
is utilitarian ethics where essentially
you can value the harm and you can value
the good and you make the decision of
what brings about the most good for the
most amount of people but if you dig a
little bit deeper what you do then off
the back of that is you can value human
life
and you could in theory say one human
life is worth more than another human
life if you're valuing different lives
in a different way it's very easy to see
how somebody who's quote unquote
Genetically Enhanced is worth more than
somebody who isn't some thinkers say
that this will lead to this could very
well lead to a war
[Music]
technology is something amazing a bionic
hand which be more accurate but I'd
rather have my imperfect human hand
I want to feel the strings to transmit
the passion and to have a hint of
transcendence
this imperfect hand creates a unique
sound with every experience in every
instant of my mortal life I want to be
mortal for two reasons the first is that
without death there is no life the
second is that immortality is for God
Alone
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]